[Music]
[Music]
hey vishnu
hey ma'am and hello everyone who is
already here
hey audio i thought i'd skip zelda today
as
you know it is international chess day
uh so i decided uh to start the day with
some
uh with some uh bullet bullet
chests uh on twitch uh if you guys are
interested
uh so i'm only chess if you guys want to
drop a challenge drop a challenge
we'll play some bullet
[Music]
and yeah uh as more people are joining
in let's uh
all congratulations let's all
congratulate everyone
the international chess day hey
kaizenbala welcome
bo uh all right
uh let's uh let's try some challenges if
we have
all right matthias mathias is here
all right let's uh start oh that's a bit
too loud let's start it with some
scandinavian
uh action
yeah i i don't think i've ever done a
bullet stream i i think i
i may have done one like a long long
time ago
but it wasn't uh playing against
subscribers it's it was more of a
i think just playing a normal alicia's
tournament
and uh yeah everyone everyone joining in
now uh
happy international chess day to to
everyone
yeah as soon as i as soon as i get
the the barnes uh merchant you guys will
be notified okay so he's not interested
in this
is a bullet let's ju he's gonna capture
here i don't mind
since i'm i'm much better on time
and that will come whoa that's that's
interesting
um yeah let's just go here defend the
knight
so okay now now he even wants to get
here that's pretty cool
that's cool he can capture here i'm just
gonna move the king nope
not even that okay
very interesting moves okay so he gives
up
all right he could have gone for for
knight f7 but
still
no okay
okay so he blocked everything but now he
will have some
oh no not there
not there okay it was a pretty good one
but i was mostly playing it on time
uh since i saw matthias was uh taking
his time
but otherwise a very very nicely very
nicely played game
who is the guy near mr barnes oh that's
yon he was in the previous stream with
me so i
i i was lazy you know to update the
interface
hey harry melrose welcome man all right
who do we have next
it's uh vishnu vishnu
uh vijay chess
uh yeah that's why i thought maybe it's
international chess day so let's just uh
i thought playing some bullet would
would definitely make sense
since uh we can get a lot more uh
we can get a lot more challenges in okay
let's just spin that guy
yeah let's capture that and go b6
let's trade off the light square bishop
and go something like
c5 followed by queen e7 and the rook
d8 okay we don't want to blunder our
knight definitely
so yeah we want to fight for this square
now
get the queen in and okay that makes
sense
that's one way to do it i don't mind
trading here
i will improve my central control
yeah that's fine that's fine
even undoubling my pawns will do let's
go here
kick away the knight and then go for
something like this
oh i pre-moved this actually so that's
pretty weird i actually pre-moved
this yeah let's go here
okay let's bring our king into the game
he will do the same
or he will trade once maybe
yeah we both want our king here
yeah let's let's trade off a pair a pair
of them
there we go okay so he gets one i don't
mind
or two two even he gets too even but i'm
much better on time so i don't mind
yeah let's go back guard this guy here
a lot of checks but
it will not do there we go let's try and
get him to do a
nice in-between move all right check get
away from there we pick up this guy with
check and now we're just now we're just
better
there we go let's push this
uh yeah let's go even for that guy okay
so we were able to flag him but we're up
a pawn so
i i guess it's fair
hey molester welcome
welcome to some previous bullet action
well almost
charabinha welcome oh i don't see the
animations uh
sorry about that i need to switch the
these guys uh these three
up there there we go okay now the
animations will be visible
yeah happy international chess day
everyone
and the dark master dark master
minecraft welcome to some premium bullet
action on
international chess day all right who do
we have next it's uh kaizen bala
someone who enjoys chess as well
uh as well as zelda
alright so we got some nice dragon
action here hopefully
but now it's just something weird
i like it i like it for black
let's go this way
and we've achieved pretty much
everything we wanted
so oh he's just playing really fast
that's that's cool
let's develop somewhat okay let's do
this for
safety go a little bit of check here get
the rook in and now push the central
pawns that's a hanging knight
so i could have captured that but i
decided to wait for the rook
and now i've wandered upon and he
doesn't want my
pawn so i'm gonna go for this
it's very interesting okay let's not
give it up now he will take this i don't
mind
uh okay it's very
interesting let's go here yeah he's just
gonna take it
okay i knew he was gonna do that not
not much i could have done there let's
go here he's gonna go back
and he's doing very well in time i'm i
can't say i'm enjoying that okay so now
this is good
oh i will have some of that action yes
and that's it that will be game
uh let's go here oh this would have been
better
simply to guard this yeah let's uh offer
a trade here
and my pawns are better here let's do
this
uh this
now he has one check but we don't mind
since now we're getting
we're getting in and that's it he has no
checks
that's good yeah he will have to block
with the queen if he wants to try and
flag this out
but other than that yeah oh yeah he
could have blocked but
good game good game man
uh international chess day arena yeah
maybe we could do that like for
for later today lastly
you you want to show some terrible
bullet skills uh
that's that's cool let's let's do that
you still have a question mark
come on you still haven't played 20
bullet games
seriously all right let's do this
oh we're gonna go for the exchange
uh i never go for the exchange variation
in anything
but in bullet i sometimes do
uh just to see how how everyone is doing
uh is there
some pre-moving action maybe going on uh
or something
let's go h4h5 just for good measure okay
he will double his pawns here
let's go here threaten this
okay it's a nice clean pawn
now we could oh that's a nice queen
leslie i think you've blundered the
queen the previous time we played also
that's uh
mighty generous but okay
it is international chess day
all right and you still had 32 seconds
so you you could have uh
you know spend some more time
but don't worry i will i will i will
blunder my queen a few times as well
it's no no worry uh himkar all right
let's do this hey red x yeti welcome to
the team man
uh all right let's do some d4 action we
can just play e
for every game all right nice
nice oh i like that let's see that
oh ho ho some nice bangko action
let's even go a4 here yeah let's
let's allow that let's allow that
all right let's undouble i mean fix our
pawn structure here
and now we're just very happy i will
even i will even take that yeah let's go
here
even here it's a very weak pawn
uh so we are going to enjoy going after
it he's gonna kick away my knight
probably okay let's let's double our
pawn but it's also a nice pass pawn
uh kind of controlling the knight i mean
f5 is strong here b6 is strong here i
guess a lot of things are strong here
but we are we are worse than time
so that's that's not cool threatening
some nasty discoveries
oh okay i will have some of that action
yes
uh and push the pawn
oh yeah we blundered that see i told you
there will be some premium blunders
uh have to be careful for some back rank
issues but other than that i think we're
good
let's go here
uh yeah let's let's just grab that
uh yeah we can't go there uh let's go
here
next capture here all right so i guess
we can't capture just yet
and we should really improve on time
yeah let's take that go here
uh here let's take that oh six seconds
six seconds is not a lot of fun
all right he blundered that because he
was he was pinned
uh but i guess it's cool all right so we
were able to do it but good game cut
that was uh that was crucial there
ah you felt necessary to sub at least
once okay thanks man
thanks man
i really like to play the karo khan in
black that's that's awesome
uh but yeah i mean don't worry i i mean
i will blunder my queen
many many a time so okay let's do let's
do a nice sip of water here
hey 21st century top welcome that's
that's a nice handle
ah the pan of attack against kharo khan
yeah
i have some good stories
of the pan of attack okay let's see
let's just see
okay let's not see i was i was going to
check if he's maybe pre-moving but
okay that's cool let's give him
oh i thought i'd give up a rook there
but he's not interested
okay what's what's happening here
it's very nice
and weird yeah let's block that
um okay
i guess it's possible yeah
how do i hide my king i wanna
castle artificially let's try this
i think that's the plan oh that's nice
that's actually very nice
let's hide the king he's gonna push this
yeah
of course he is of course he is let's
block that
he's very aggressive i'm gonna sacrifice
my queen here
to make it a little bit more interesting
all right he
he could have got gone for check but he
decided to go for this
all right let's capture that now it's
pretty crazy
pretty crazy let's go further back
and this guy here defends this the
knight jump
nothing um let's
push the pass pawn i guess let's deliver
a check first and then push the pass
pawn first
oh now there's a triple attack here
let's let's go back
oh that's nice and that's mate oh good
game man
good game it was too too quick to
sacrifice the queen like that but
ah you have sub emotes yeah i know you
have sub emotes since uh
i think uh hexatonka has gifted you
the the sub good game man
that was uh that was very clean all
right we have
uh mo lester all right mo lester is here
is zagat motorino here
uh i wasn't following the chat
i'm not seeing him in the chat
but if he's in the chat uh make sure to
congratulate him as it is his birthday
today
all right let's do some of that
poggy walkers welcome poggy vloggers all
right let's trade here go knight c3
unless he pre-moves yeah i thought he
might do that
okay molester it's very clean
let's go uh for some pawn action here
yeah let's go like this
okay that's uh what is this
that's nothing yeah we have check here
so that's why
we're kind of better but not really oh
that's that's silly
oh that's silly yeah had to go for this
okay
now i just want a piece which shouldn't
have happened
he just gave it to me for no reason
uh yeah let's go here end here
okay i i guess
there we go nice mate since the pawn
covers this
good game mo lester
uh all right we have uh ah filipino
philbin you also play bullet i never
knew you played bullet
oh i am here uh again is not here yeah
it's his birthday so
he's probably taking it easy
yeah let's try this some nice checking
maneuvers yeah let's do this
trade trade trade even this
uh filipino is very strong but uh he
might be
a bit slower than me so that's gonna be
what i will be trying to do
all right yeah i guess so
there we go um
yeah let's do this there we go
oh he had this actually that's a shame
a shame he had that
uh let's go here and here
okay i didn't just allow that but let's
push this pawn
here and let's bring the king into the
game
yeah let's push b5 he has this we don't
really care about that
uh oh yeah we we create a pass pawn here
no questions asked
let's go here he's gonna push this
probably no
uh now we can actually switch
yeah let's do this and trade a pair of
rooks here
like this okay he's much faster
but it's cool it's cool yeah let's take
care of this guy
check and bring our king into the game
there we go
yeah i think we i think we don't
trade here oh we're down to seven
seconds that's pretty pretty
awful
that's pretty awful yeah let's take that
and push
no i pre-moved that for no reason oh man
oh man oh man
i pre-moved and here oh man
good game man i was i was the slower one
i thought you would be the slower one
that's crazy that's crazy good game man
hey i'm kings kings for crusher
welcome welcome to the team
all right that was a that was a wild one
yeah you should but with one second on
the clock i i thought
i made a good pre-move but in fact it
was a bad one
all right d4d5c for knight f6 do we play
that all right i'm pre-moving d5 i'm
expecting d4
hey no problem rv uh
is it c4 alright knight f6 there we go
we played what he asked us to play
and we're even gonna guard the disc to
see what happens yeah let's go
c6 let's go this
we're we're guarding our pawn
okay maybe maybe not the the greatest
but what are you gonna do
okay that's uh that's uh something
we don't wanna face yeah okay e5 coming
i guess we go c5 now or
yeah i guess we do yeah he doesn't want
to play a4
which is kind of crucial here okay so we
will take that
now we have a like a brilliant pawn
center he does have some
sacrificing ideas here which is cool
uh which is cool
and i hope we don't get checkmated here
yeah queen g3 doesn't allow me to
capture it's pretty
pretty good yeah we will capture now or
or we won't
i have no idea what to play here that's
pretty crazy
yeah we don't want to allow that bishop
here
will take away a few crucial squares
away from the from the white queen
and now we can take without fearing for
our life
there we go now the bishop is good the
rook is good we're going for this
yeah let's take that and we oh
that's actually nice i i didn't think of
that
wow it's actually pretty good
all right pass pawns do your thing
do your thing past pawns all right now
i'm
okay i don't want to give up this so i'm
just going to push the pass pawn this is
a crucial pawn
not the blunder
all right yeah we will have that
check and push the pawn okay i will take
that
all right so that was very nice
how long am i going to accept challenges
well i don't know maybe like for an hour
we'll see yeah this is a close close one
close one
have to have to play faster hey leon
beast
leon beast from the from the previous
stream
omaselite and height welcome
uh i should play one plus two so the
games last longer i'm actually trying to
make the games
last shorter so i can accept more
challenges
that's uh that's the the idea
i'm not i'm not trying to make the game
okay let's see if there's
any pre-moving action here nope
let's push that let's sacrifice the rook
if he goes for it yeah let's uh
make some make some room here
okay interesting
this opens up our uh e5
ideas and we can go
we can go here i don't really care
yeah we can take that
okay let's threaten mate here try and be
sneaky about it
oh he he picked it up but that just
blunders the queen
so yeah good game man it was a it was a
crazy one i thought that
rook sacrifice was maybe a bit crazy but
if it if it works you know why not
all right attil attil welcome matil
jose in redrum welcome to the to the
team man
yeah let's go e5 to see if he's
pre-moving which he is
so that's cool now we know he's a
pre-mover and we will play accordingly
let oh that's a interesting
yeah not giving any yeah we're taking
taking these squares
so the he might have some knight here
action but
i'm not buying it yeah okay we've
cleared pretty much everything we don't
want something like this since we really
like our bishop here yeah let's threaten
mate he's probably gonna defend it
somehow
yeah threaten a double attack on the
rook here
uh yeah i'm first gonna trade so yeah he
he will take with the bishop
i was i was hoping he wouldn't since uh
yeah there's no good way to deal with
this this is much better
yeah now he kind of has to play f3
and it's uh well it's it's a very
interesting position to say the least
and we're doing better on time so we
might be able to to pull this off oh he
found a way how to trade queens
damn damn i was hoping that wouldn't
happen
yeah let's defend this guy he's probably
gonna play c4
i blundered my rook wow oh
okay good game man all right yeah
the rook was right behind my microphone
that that that
tends to happen sometimes
yeah we had uh we had uh we had a plan
but
the the microphone blunder got in the
way
yeah yeah i did hey mr twitch account
welcome man
but no worries it's international chess
day
it's uh it's a fun day for chess so we
should
uh that's a free pawn but we're gonna
win it back so it's cool
unless we don't yeah he gives it back
right away i thought he might
not give it back but he did i'll go c6
and now try and develop our pieces
somehow yeah this
kind of makes sense to give up a pawn
here
just uh just to get some development in
yeah let's let's open up the c file
since his queen is on the c file i guess
it could make sense yeah he's not
allowing any development so that's
uh that's smart that's very smart yeah
we're gonna give up another pawn and try
and play faster
there's no no other way to do this yeah
let's
develop here and try and make the best
of it
so we're threatening this he didn't see
it so we're very happy about that
it's kind of kind of the only thing we
had going for us
okay that's uh another another freebie
okay good game
uh yeah i don't stream much no but i i
started streaming on twitch now
mostly zelda though however i thought
the mailman how how do you know i mean i
i actually am expecting the mailman
uh i'm expecting two packages
uh rick ewas rick hey
soccer soccer cobra welcome man do i
play someone the second time
i first tried to clear all the
challenges uh and then
i will go through everyone again but
there aren't all that many so i
we probably will manage
okay we're gonna play it with a6
since it's uh okay let's let's let's
make it fun
uh we're not uh we're not kidding anyone
we're here to
to have a good time uh let's go even
yeah let's not go e5 or do we go e5 yeah
let's go
let's go e5 see what happens
oh that's pretty cool yeah he wants to
trade everything
i guess that's fine
um i will capture this if he doesn't
move it yeah i mean
let's prepare g5
let's keep attacking even without the
queen okay let's try
let's try something sneaky
try something sneaky i want to get mo i
want to move my knight
uh wow that's not what i was going for
at all actually
but we can always try to trap this guy
all right he doesn't he doesn't buy it
he's gonna double up rooks which is fine
i guess
and now it's not fine yeah now it's not
fine
now he can do whatever he wants it's
pretty pretty wild
yeah let's defend the rook from here i
mean we don't have anything else
i will take that although
although not really yeah i have to play
this
pretty nasty yeah i have to give up a
pawn
just to grab this
so if he captures at least i have check
and now i free myself
there we go and let's trade everything
off
unless he has some really awesome bishop
action which i think he actually did
have
yeah i will take that okay so now
[Music]
now he's much better obviously okay now
he's not much better since he
wandered upon and we are going to flag
him
yeah he's trying to pre-move but it's
still not
time for pre-moving yeah this was
actually very good you were better uh
but
i was uh sneakier when it came to you
know the last few seconds
simon's welcome man welcome samuts
yeah the mailman attack is coming most
most likely
robin sucks why would robin suck
which robin i mean there are many robin
of loxley
oh that was you order a chest good game
over at chess it was uh
it was very close uh declan
uh we haven't played against declan
yeah he probably wants to hear my voice
before he rings the bell so you know he
knows i'm either recording or streaming
i think that's how yeah that's how the
mailman rolls definitely
is this leeches yeah this is leeches all
right let's go for some b
for action give up another pawn he
doesn't want it
let's check if he's a pre-mover he's not
which makes me very sad
let's go here castle
all right so our pieces are kind of
doing something
but not really
uh let's go even f4 no f4 loses
the queen b6 so that would be very sad
okay we do have some uh bishop action
going on here
so let's get the rook into the game
bring the knight into the game
yeah i don't want to trade not just yet
i really like this
yeah i really really like this um
yeah i'm opening myself to some
discoveries here now
so i'm gonna try we're gonna try and
keep everything he's probably
gonna play this the block block any
mating threats
yeah bishop there is also very good now
he took care of everything
uh pretty much once and for all but we
will bring our knight
in and try to use our light square
bishop now for the attack
which i guess also makes sense hope he
captures so we have some queen action
here
yeah not much but it's something
we can also pick up the g7 pawn so
that's cool
okay so he gave up this pawn so we don't
have to take the g7 pawn okay we will
take that
he seems to be pre-moving a lot no we
don't now he brought his uh
his dude here yeah still not trading
sorry
sorry dude okay let's deliver check here
and let's uh let's go here
which is pretty weird why would someone
do this
why would someone do this and losing
time jesus
there we go oh he he saw that
okay wow 0.0.4
seconds good job man i pre-moved queen
captures bishop
but it was it was too fast it was too
fast good game man
all right we played attil uh go baiji
sveely
all right go big really
no good username left for me welcome to
the to the channel
although that's a pretty good username
actually
niffy coffee link niffy coffee link
welcome man
all right have to have to boost speed
all right let's go plus 15 to agility
let's trade off everything play c6 block
the queen
let's bring the rook here prepare this
yeah let's do it while
while the d file is you know i will grab
a pawn here even at the price of
doubling my pawns
since uh i don't think like it's a bad
pawn it i think it's a pretty good pawn
actually
let's put the queen here get the knight
in there
yeah he could have oh he's going for
mate that's actually pretty clever
yeah that's pretty clever we're going
back for now
yeah all right so king and pawn let's
play king and pawn
uh i actually don't mind that that
actually helps me quite a lot
so we're just going to create a pass
pawn here and win the game
pretty easily i hope yeah
all right let's let's mess up his pawn
structure there and
just finish it there we go
that was pretty clean good game
good game gobei jishvili uh let's uh
let's do another quick one
sorry uh there are quite a lot of
follows so
uh shinty and ant unbalance
uh automizer uh tt engine tien tint pro
uh j4jc3f uh welcome everyone nico grazo
welcome guys
and tuner welcome tuner
uh let me just check something real
quick
yeah that's cool
[Music]
uh yeah tuner welcome man uh all right
so who do we have molester we played
molester attil we played
uh daksh dakshba dakshiba
all right we haven't played the daksuba
oh neat and clean finish yeah i guess i
guess it was
uh all right let's see if duck oh a nice
serretti
well we've done some uh we've done some
research on directive so
i do not mind playing the red t
alright yeah i could have gone for
bishop g4 right away
which would make a lot of sense here
but i am enjoying that he's uh wasting a
lot of time on this
okay now he stopped it yeah so that
that's cool
that's very cool let's trade off this
guy
his bishop is much better than mine
okay so kind of hoping to get this in
yeah he blocks it uh so let's get try
and get rid of the dark square bishop
and now prepare it
all right so now we now we got a nice
clean trade-off i don't even want to
capture on g3 since it's uh
it's a very um could be could be very
dangerous
yeah that's good i was actually thinking
of going f5 now g5
could be good yeah because i'm
threatening this yeah this is pretty
good
just to open up his uh you know files a
little bit yeah let's go even further
now everything is hanging now this is
good
now this is hanging okay
uh makes sense yeah
definitely makes sense
yeah could have played that a little bit
better but what are you gonna do
yeah he's gonna go for oh even that
that's cool that's cool
yeah let's do this probably going to
bring another rook into the game
now we do this he delivers an attack on
the queen
yeah we we saw that we check here trade
off everything
and we win on time that's how we do it
nope not going to
give that check even though i could
i'm going to give this one yeah good
game ducks b
uh crxv welcome man and our mantis and
future magnus carlsen also welcome man
when are you going to see the evans
gambit i hope i hope
soon candy bar oh candy bar
that's clever
and thank you for the follow also thank
you for the follow thank you for the
follow
uh burton
neet knit evil hey bro
dooms jeff welcome tom's jeff all right
we're we're
uh quitting with the scandinavian for a
bit but we are
returning to it at some point so okay
again we get a pretty weird
situation over here
okay so he he wants to trade everything
and keep that e5 pawn
or he he he doesn't even want to keep it
so that's cool
that's cool we got a strong center and
this knight here
doing good work
yeah i guess we can trade here
interesting uh let's go here
i usually wouldn't play c4 but i just
might hear since this bishop
is annoying and after i push c4 this
bishop will not be annoying
yeah he heard me that's that's good
let's go rook here
go for some some mating ideas uh let's
go here there's a nice hole there
uh let's threaten this just for fun he's
gonna play
b3 yeah let's go for a nice uh some nice
check here
um yeah let's go let's check him there
and now yeah now we can play this we
don't really care about ruining our pawn
structure now since
i feel that our attack is very strong
yeah with bishop going in and everything
now c4 c4 is very good okay do i have to
be worried about the dark squares yeah i
kind of do
i kind of do need to worry about the
dark squares here
okay i'm gonna try and set up a block
eight okay i was actually
thinking he would go for this but yeah
let's go for this now
let's go for this this and bring the
rook and he's gonna threaten mate
so i just completely blundered this
yeah good thing
yeah let's trade off everything and just
try and win this
king and pawn end game oh no oh i'm solo
on time
oh man burton good game man
good game burton that was very clean
that was very clean yeah we should we
should
speed up
no i did not uh i saw little bits of uh
evan chooks interview yesterday
yesterday but not the whole one i was i
was saving it for today
austen powell austin powell hey welcome
dannyboy15 let's do this yeah i imagine
it was awesome but
every chuck interview is awesome
all right let's go for this
all right he challenges us to some great
theory
duel which i'm sure i will not win
what is that that's pretty interesting
that's pretty interesting
all right so he can play d3 here and
make it like a super interesting game
i don't know
yeah king f8 and we have a super
interesting game
okay
that's the stuff oh he blocks it this
way
to get the bishop in
could be could be
queen f6 uh takes care of all of his
issues
i'm actually gonna try and sacrifice my
queen here to go for this mate maybe he
falls for it if we're lucky
no he didn't go for it that's that's
shame but we're still gonna
keep this diagonal alive i guess no
we're not yeah let's just double there
double here and
yeah he defended well which is cool
yeah i'm gonna try and go for that i
will go for
that
so i'm gonna try and speed up here we
don't want to lose another game on time
there we go so now there are no moving
the bishop
yeah let's even try and force that okay
so that's a free bishop
okay and okay
and we threaten mate he's gonna push
this guy we're gonna block it and now
it's very dangerous how do you stop mate
well you don't good game man that was
very clean you avoided everything
i missed the win oh i probably have yeah
probably chess daily raiguru and the
unnamed comet welcome guys
welcome guys uh
all right erica wow we played uh panther
yen's pantry jens we haven't played
pantherians mido
welcome to the team mido alright so
we're black against panther jens
from india
uh c4 all right we go for e5 we go for
e5 and we fight for d5
there we go we got it let's
push see if he's pre-moving but he's not
no one's pre-moving anymore what happens
to all the
to all the pre-movers this used to be a
great pre-moving game i'm actually gonna
capture that
just uh you know do some damage although
i actually think his
dark square bishop is very strong here
let's go for the rook
see what happens challenge the queen
maybe some f3 action no
it's interesting it's very interesting
what's the queen doing wow
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
is there like a super hidden mate here
no there isn't
oh i actually blundered my queen here
that's pretty cool
it's pretty pretty awesome
okay i have to be careful for the queen
queen drop
yeah we have to develop the the knight
first then we can go for
some some threats because it's getting
very very interesting
okay free rook what's happening
and attack the oh yeah free rook yeah
as if i didn't even see he attacked my
queen
let's try and get some uh discoveries in
and try and win this on time which i
don't think
is all that possible yeah
not at all not at all all right let's
take that
and go back here go here try and get
this
check in come on yeah we did get the
check
although it was uh pretty useless yeah
let's take that
threaten this go back oh yeah thank you
for that
okay now we're now we're kind of playing
the end game
which is pretty cool all right yes we
were able to do it good game panther
yens
that was that was crazy
when do i plan to end the morphe saga
well when it ends we still have plenty
of games
will i consider moving all the streams
to twitch uh
at some point probably yeah at some
point probably
not yet uh but maybe like in uh
in a year no no sorry not a year maybe a
few months time
we'll see
oh it is like a creation like a bullet
in your hand
kakodaro
couldn't read that one yeah that's a lot
of moonshine that that is a lot of
moonshine
there we go go for some exchange action
see what's happening yeah not a
pre-mover and also
quite oh that's a blunder he could have
taken advantage of that
easily okay one check
to see if he's a king of eight man
i don't think he is yeah he is he's a
king of eight man
let's get our knight to a nice central
outpost
yeah now we win this guy here
with the queen even yeah that's a
beautiful past pawn now yeah this is
coming
so you can't really save the night
yeah that's pretty good pretty good
hopefully we win the rook here yeah we
do go back
trade off the last remaining stuff
and yeah uh
g4 was actually better here
all right uh let's trade off the
remaining stuff
uh he's trying to to take advantage of
this rook
being undefended so that's that's cool
yeah okay now we end now we end
all right good good game man
had the other rook took yeah probably i
mean uh it's bullet
uh you know we we we don't see every we
don't see everything in classical let
alone in
bullet beat this welcome man
ah you are from croatia actually zero
tonics
where from exactly
oh we have a george but first we're
gonna accept a few
uh without the question mark uh and for
cheshire and for cheshire
are you you you you you lost to andrew
tang in bullet and he only used five
seconds
that means andrew took his time andrew
can it can beat you in like two seconds
unless you're a strong grandmaster five
seconds is all andrew needs
he's just he's just that strong
all right let's get c for in we're
hoping for alpa
uh and that's that's good yeah let's
not allow any weird stuff here
some discoveries he's not interested oh
yeah
pre-mover spotted free movers oh you
resign right away
ah you don't resign in bullet after
blundering a piece
all right oh chess essentials is here
oh playing chess again instead of
uh playing chess instead of uh
crash bandicoot and you you could have
done so much already
there we go
makes sense
check if he's a pre-mover he's not
it's too bad i thought
i thought he might be one yeah let's go
here
uh he's probably gonna trade off the
bishop at some point
yeah let's okay threatening mate i like
it
i like that let's go here
bring the rook in yeah not
interested in that uh he will push this
at some point i guess
so c3 makes sense uh let's trade
everything off
like that okay so we trade off the final
one as well
yeah we can't capture actually here yeah
he has a nice pass pawn and we can't
capture it because of
uh because of mate so that's pretty sad
but we will take care of this guy
and hope he pre-moves a little bit
oh no we're not close enough
yeah he's 29 seconds good game man oh
we're not close enough but that was good
juan king zimas that's uh that's good
stuff
good game chess essentials weren't you
at 2600
with your bullet rating what happened to
the to the 100
you said you were gonna you said you
were gonna save the save the rating
ah only blitz only blitz ah okay
boom beach master 2.
ah you are saving the 2500 that's that's
that makes sense
maybe they start awarding the the grand
master bullet title
and maybe you know you'll be ready for
it
uh okay let's let's make it fun
no no one wants to make it fun
that's a free pawn
still not interested okay uh let's get
this guy here he no longer is needed on
this file
yeah that's a that's a cleverly placed
knight
okay that is a bit weird
ah yeah i'm not focusing on a zelda
speed run now uh because but there's a
good reason
that i'm not it's uh it's international
chess day so i thought
uh you know if it makes sense to play
chess
at any day it's today so we're going to
capture this
as we kind of want it if he captures
this then this is mate
well not really he will give up the
queen but still
boom beach master good game man
where in croatia am i from it's uh it's
a town called kriegertz
near zagreb
audra uh thanks for joining us other
chess
and yeah a nice game it was a very close
one
uh all right we've played you we haven't
played cop
cop verletsung
ah you're from kosovo welcome man
uh let's go f4 a nice king's gambit
bullet we can't get
a nice game of evan's gambit oh he goes
for this
it's actually very nice yeah let's trade
i'm not familiar with this so we're just
gonna trade what queen f6
no that's uh although queen f6 could be
good
i'm not saying it isn't i'm not saying
it's not good
uh yeah that's just
that's just greedy of everyone
and he keeps the bishop pair bishop c5
check
so what did we get here actually i think
nothing
i don't think we actually got anything
good let's uh
attack that bishop try and get b4c5 in
just to make it interesting
and try and uh be better on time
always oh did i just blundermate oh yeah
i did
yeah i did that's pretty crazy
that's pretty crazy was trying to be
better on time
and whoa and he has this come on
come on good game man cope fairlets and
good game
yeah we there's a there's a pattern here
oh again motorino is here
[Music]
uh cass is welcome and happy birthday i
got motorino
uh it must be must be great
and yeah it wasn't it was made because i
could block with my knight and the
bishop covers g1 so he just captures it
with mate yeah
it was mate
uh what what a pleasure to have your
birthday on the international chess day
it's pretty pretty crazy
knight was protecting yeah but then uh
the bishop was also guarding g1
and then queen just captures knight so
so we in fact did blundermate all right
i got matarina doing better on time
i like that so we're gonna do this
trade once guarded the pawn
and try and get this in
okay that's that's very brave mighty
brave let's threaten
now knight c7 would be kind of stronger
yeah let's do it now now he has to
capture it
and yeah let's just go back
now let's just capture this guy
okay that's very nice let's capture this
and see what happens
okay let's uh let's uh
go for this
seems reasonable okay let's
let's go back
push c4 i'm just trying to win on time
here
since now he's very low okay
again you have 0.2 seconds next moves
pre-move this
and this and you win uh uh i'm not going
to defend against it there we go
no pre-move that remove that come on
[Music]
come on i wanted you to remove this for
your birthday
but you you just wanted to flag me
that's not cool
yeah i know there's uh yeah okay there's
like a five second
uh there's like a five second delay uh
in the
uh in the stream uh from when i said it
but yeah since it's your birthday you
you get a rematch if you want to rematch
yeah flagging is better than mate most
of the times
ah you close the twitch tab
alright since uh
since it's your birthday we have to play
something accordingly
all right
let's see how far we can get
all right very very interesting
let's go here
uh okay i knew you were gonna do that
okay let's get that knight somewhere
hard to say where but we oh that's a
good square for the rook if it ever
lands there
let's try and get our rook here could be
very nice
how is the bishop to be defended
okay we're not gonna capture it it is
his birthday we're not gonna capture it
uh yeah that's a free square for the
rook for the night now
uh let's get the other guy in
and hopefully get our bishop in somehow
like this maybe
okay now we will catch he's down to nine
seconds what's a sneaky way
to play this oh he's just removing the
king that's pretty clever
it's pretty clever all right
let's uh let's go back let's go back
let's go back let's go back all right
there we go
good draw man good draw man
that's uh that was a fine fine
pre-moving maneuver
there we go yes an immortal birthday
game
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right good job man uh
oh disgrace
also with the wing this is a battle of
two leeches supporters
let's do this
oh yeah mr krabs welcome man
all right so again we're gonna go for
the exchange something something
yeah let's go here let's try c5 just to
see what's happening oh he's not gonna
allow it
let's give up a few pawns just to make
it interesting
yeah i was hoping for that one as well
it's not gonna be like super interesting
but
it might be a little bit interesting
yeah we're not gonna trade there we're
just gonna position our bishops here
to be like super fierce and get our
knights in so
just slowly but surely get our pieces
closer to the black king yeah we want to
counter that rook
i would say yeah no we're not trading
okay that is that's cool that's cool
uh yeah not trading there not just yet
okay uh g4
seems fierce
yeah let's get our queen into the game
as well
trying to get something like this in uh
let's go f4 as well
try open up everything let's go here
now we have some threats already okay
now he's he's the one threatening mate
so we have to we have to trade now
oh he also blundered the queen uh let's
let's try that again okay
oh that was super fun
that was actually super fun yeah now we
just have to abort
we have to abort mate
okay that's cool
yeah we can't capture there yeah or
there
or there
oh we're totally getting bullied here
all right passport activated past pawn
activated
there we go
oh nice i pre-moved g5 but he
also pre-moved g5 therefore nullifying
my pre-move
that was a good one
yes uh don't forget to congratulate the
international chess day to all of your
friends
uh everywhere matthias exa welcome man
yeah that was a great endgame technique
just you know
uh pre-moving to prevent pre-moving
that's you know
total inception stuff there
there we go i'm gonna play c3 probably
yeah probably something weird atlas
welcome to the team atlas
great great to have you on the team okay
let's try and force a trade here
get the rook in something something
yeah let's bring that bishop back
um yeah that's that's good
that's good we're not really defending
anything here
there we go okay so we are worse
we are worse but we are happy we are
worse but we are happy there we go
yeah i will trade that just to pick up
this pawn
and now regarding from any checks we're
hoping to pick off some pawns which he
allows so that's
that's very good for us now we're going
to push the past pawn
he we don't care about this guy here
oh he don't he doesn't have like a
perpetual or anything
uh or or does he
yeah he might he actually might have
let's check him here
free night oh no free night no free
night for me
let's go here yeah he found that
although
this might have also been a reasonable
plan
yeah not happening we're keeping an eye
on that square
yeah okay now we're just gonna threaten
to pick up the knight
we give up the pawn for a piece it's
also
yeah also something
yeah let's do this get the king here so
we don't have to worry about any checks
along the way oh i actually will have
that
i am very confident in winning this end
game
ah there we go there we go there we go
yes i was actually planning on
winning the end game i was actually
planning on flagging him in the end game
hey anarmar welcome man
welcome to the team how many videos do i
have no i don't have five thousand
i don't i don't have five thousand uh i
actually have uh
like only a few uh like eighteen hundred
ahedra shishta welcome man
yeah that was uh that was a pretty
pretty wild one
one second left yeah crazy stuff yeah
800
1800 ish
uh all right who who who haven't we
accepted yet we have accepted we have
accepted we have accepted that's a five
plus three we're not playing five plus
three for the moment
kois we have not accepted kois
yes i have more videos than your rating
that is true
that is true okay that's a nice
nice pawn blunder right from the start
i like that let's get rid of that guy
there
all right so giving up a few pawns to
make the game interesting
now we have this open uh
we'll see um yeah let's uh
let's let's throw this in just for fun
and he will capture that as well
i like that i like his style it's
actually pretty pretty awesome
all right so naturally he will do that
we'll go here
to kind of bother this guy
it's pretty reasonable to capture this
so we've
we gave up all of our pawns the
to open up some lines here which we are
always happy to do let's take that and
threaten mate
so now this guy's vulnerable but we are
threatening mate so
we will give it a few seconds and now
we're gonna do this to go for this
and see if it's possible yeah we still
go for that
now the bishop will try and prevent us
from doing this
although yeah this was also a move but i
don't think
yeah okay now now we've kind of messed
up but i think this is
still a move yeah he's gonna capture
this bishop now
so we're gonna capture what are we going
to capture
there's nothing good to capture here wow
that's pretty pretty sad
yeah let's let's go all the way back
capture this guy
luckily he doesn't have mate so we don't
have to worry about that
check all right now he's ju
now he just allowed mate he had to block
with king g7 but i
we're still winning here yeah we're
still winning here
koi's good good game man
am i playing a bot or a person no i'm
playing uh whoever wants to play
just challenge the bullet and we play
all right uh rasmutali we played uh ah
we have not played no problem man
ah that's why you have the the question
mark next to your rating
okay it's not a problem
uh another king's gambit on the
on the rise there we go oh that's an
interesting one
baiting me to overextend i like it
let's castle and pick up that pawn
like that all right
a nice nice developing move while
attacking the queen
now he wants the castle queen side we
don't mind we actually we actually want
to prepare it
oh he will grab that that's interesting
it's very interesting okay so he now he
he really opened up
uh some possibilities here since the
queen is now captured
we are going to okay
so we're very happy here uh yeah let's
take that uh
yeah okay good game man it was a
it was a it was a pretty greedy pawn
grab but you know in bullet i guess
everything
everything goes throwaway compiler
welcome man and
also everyone else
yeah argan matarina says it well
all right i think we kind of fought
everyone
oh no there's botvini we have not played
against betweening 64.
yeah we haven't had a michelle tiles
saga we only covered his uh
well 1959 candidates tournament and his
match against botwinni but
uh yeah we did not have a saga okay
bishop f2 very nice
i like it let's castle artificially
there
maybe rook f1 was also an idea
it's a very very bold very bold move
uh yeah let's capture this and we're
bringing the bishop over to this
diagonal either way
uh yeah let's do this
and bring the rook in he wants to push
that probably
all right let's uh let's create a past
pawn keep this tension here
if he goes g5 that i'm not convinced
there was this of course yeah
there was this but in bullet you know
you can't see everything
okay now we will see it there we go
clindor welcome clindor uh that's uh
that's actually a great question
who did came second in the 1959
candidates tournament that's uh
that's the only relevant question
what is happening here
yeah i it's not the the most uh
inspiring way to play i would say but
yeah i i i do want to trick him now okay
you haven't played in many years yeah of
course
do do uh do keep your friends at the bar
in library well informed
especially about questions like this
the zombie shooter welcomes ivy shooter
hey clindor from hungary hey man uh
who do we have uh timber avicii
timber gavichi
uh okay back to the scandinavian we've
been streaming for how long for
an oh already for an hour really wow
time flies when you're playing bullets
like literally
uh yeah let's just develop
and yeah let's make it interesting maybe
he will be the one that wants to make it
interesting no he isn't he wants to
trade down before that
so we're just gonna yeah we're even
gonna capture that
like this threaten to capture that
with check and now go e5 yeah although
this was also hanging so
let's just make it good we actually
don't mind
this we can block the rook with bishop
what is that
that's pretty weird
what is he doing the end what
okay let's let's let's even capture this
he gave us a queen let's at least give
it back to rook
but now it's kind of pointless our rook
also called the pig will just remain
here on the seventh rank
and we're gonna go gobble up everything
with the king
there we go and unless he resigns we are
going to promote
all of our pawns
there we go there we go
oh it's getting crazy it's getting crazy
will there be a stalemate
no he doesn't allow me to to promote
them if you allowed it
all the way to here it would be it would
be you know
uh fair to allow even further but but
okay
good game man tim bergavichi uh
let's excelsior we haven't played
excelsior
yeah that's the the invincible seven
pawn rush
the seven deadly pawns move that is true
okay let's see if he spots bishop here
he didn't i like that
let's push that knight away okay free
free piece i like that okay now we can
go back
and enjoy the rest of the game
so sicilian b4 action always always
popular
uh yeah interesting
interesting
yeah we kind of have to make room for
the bishop here
uh yeah let's force that although
it's basically he who forced it but okay
still defending it three times so not
worried
he's coming here yeah we don't mind that
let's go h4 knight here
bring the queen into the game and
deliver mate
no he stops us he stops us from doing
what we want to do how do we
how do we get this spawn out of here
some g4 action maybe
oh yeah we have to play f4 here
yeah although we can't make this rook go
for a rook lift
oh no i i got it sacrifice this that's
the stuff
no what is happening here
what is happening here it's pretty crazy
let's go here
yeah we're not actually threatening
anything this is just just
for fun i'm hoping he moves his queen so
i can capture this oh yeah we're taking
that
no worries no worries
all right still trying to do that let's
do this
yeah not happening let's bring that guy
back
that's the stuff okay go back
uh go here yeah let's block
uh wow that's pretty crazy
oh we're getting made it seriously we're
getting mated with one second
oh i wanted to make a clean game with
rook captures and then
uh that's what that's what happens when
you're greedy never be greedy
uh great game excelsior
hicario for uh tony kipster
nate meister welcome guys
oh hydro uh also welcome we already
played
uh since i'm the only one playing you
can challenge to both rated and unrated
doesn't really matter
uh blitz arrow welcome blitzero
yeah i mean i'm not a i'm not a greedy
punk rapper i was actually trying to
give up my rook
but he he spotted it and the the rest is
history
ricky 54 hip hop one two three four
welcome guys
and also uh odai k and st
asti davesworth rook roller is the
username all right
rook roller sorry it's bullet i have to
improve my speed
we are wasting a lot of time here he
doesn't want to capture on f6 so we will
grab this guy
yeah and now if he goes this this and
this we're dead
we're dead okay he he he spares us
it was a good thing to try we're we're
getting this thing we could have done it
to move earlier
but i guess i guess everything is fine
uh let's go this this this something
something
let's try and threaten mate like this
okay it's not made now that he played f3
but
we're still hoping for it okay that's a
double attack here on the rook and on
the bishop the bishop
is what is that
the bishop is defended so it's not
really a double attack okay will he trap
my queen
uh i guess he could yeah let's grab that
no one ever lost the game by pawn
grabbing
i i'm sure alright so let's
uh uh get some more squares in
where is the bishop going that is that's
a good question yeah
uh oh he attacked the queen first
so now he has this but now we have this
so it's really really really crazy yeah
let's
develop before we do anything like this
take away some squares from the queen as
well
all right that was that was pretty
pretty crazy blitzing arrow
ice forge ice welcome man and georgia
the plus man
james james is seven welcome guys
can a fellow creation get one game in
sure just
challenge to uh to a bullet and we're
accepting all the challenges we're not
picky here like kaze kaze is here we
haven't played against kaze and now we
accept qazi's challenge
miko gizlo and duruvi welcome guys
all right so we are going to
play some sort of an exchange here
immediate e5 let's see if he's a
pre-mover no he's not
i'm very sad when someone is not a
pre-mover so we opened up his file for
the rook but
uh he decided to castle he didn't want
to make it like a truly a crazy game
which is fine
uh where is that night going
that's always always an interesting
question
yeah i guess he trades here no he
doesn't like that's
pretty pretty interesting
it's actually very interesting i'm i'm
at a loss
of what the play here
yeah seems like uh seems like a capture
fest
is is happening here
okay but now he actually he actually
wins a piece with this that's
it's not good we are doing better on
time though so we're hoping to
to improve at least a little bit here
okay so what's that
that's pretty weird he has to capture
with the pawn now and that's not fun
or with the queen oh he actually decides
to give back the piece i like that
i like his style yeah i like his style
there we go uh yeah let's keep an eye on
that pawn and not waste too much time
yeah g6 of course of course g6
uh yeah yeah he's doing very well
he's really doing well trying to trick
us yeah he's never capturing that so
it's not
not an issue there we go
let's now it's flagging time yeah we're
no longer playing this
uh as a real game
there we go and mate there we go good
game kaze
good game ah when you try to pre-move in
real life
that also happens yeah that also happens
that can also happen i want you
i want to make you become a pre-mover i
make you want to become a pre-mover
yeah nothing wrong with that hey welcome
jay trucks welcome jaytrucks
uh all right let's see what's what's
happening
do we have any new commerce any
newcomers okay we played we played we
played we played
it's hard for me to remember everyone we
played but i'm sure we played
uh oh rookie roller yeah we haven't
played rookie roller
uh tread gill threat gill welcome man
and also
win quit that's uh that's a fine handle
wink wit
winkwit sounds like a lord's name
you know from some sort of uh some sort
of a fantasy tale
okay
uh yeah that's uh that's pretty cool
so okay now it's a free piece it wasn't
but now it is
all right are we blundering something
hopefully we're not
we're not allowing him to castle which
is always fun now that's a free queen
or do we also have mate
yeah that was pretty crazy okay but now
it's mate we don't need the queen
okay rookie roller uh very interesting
game
thank you for that
it's pretty pretty crazy yeah the
royalist
the royalist of forks trogdor the cat
welcome
trogdor the cat and marco matomate marco
matomate
yeah it's not it's not a rick rolling
it's a rook rolling
uh i should play some gambits that's a
good good idea
i i'm pretty sure i've played the gambit
every game so far
uh rusty battle player welcome man
uh e dude
edudemo seva welcome me dude mo seva
hey mr knight thank you for the 200 bits
man
no not the jerome we do not play the
jerome on this channel
because we play the evans gambit on this
channel
i try and give up my b4 pawn in the
sicilian every game but my opponent
never
wants to take it so let's uh
do something like this he's not he's not
worried that he just lost a piece i like
that
it's very nice yeah let's prevent knight
before
uh get this knight in yeah of course he
wants to give us more pieces
uh are there discoveries here i think
there are some like this
something like this with a double check
here oh
he doesn't want it it's crazy
it's crazy man
i think he should have gone for it but
yeah like what what what is happening
here
all right let's take that take that is
this really happening
uh yeah let's take everything
take everything from there
uh yeah is there a check a nice check
here
there is probably always
all right so let's bring our knight back
since he will try and flag us we know
that
we know that much
and now we're gonna get as many queens
as possible
there we go
move it
there we go
we we have to play like this when
someone wants the
wants to flag us okay i i have a queen
pre-move turned on so
[Music]
i can't really grab something else
otherwise i would
there we go that's a that's a nice
structure
a real schnitzel uh welcome man
and also everyone else who who came in
uh
while we were enjoying this game oh yeah
that's dirty that is dirty
but we needed one we needed one it is
international chess day after all we
can't just you know
finish games without any any thought
you know uh dilemma we have not played
the dilemma yeah we have not played
dilemma
hey hangelman and dyslexia welcome
all right so we're still at it with the
scandinavian i guess
uh i'm in central european time
okay my neighbors are drilling something
so if you can hear any drilling uh
i'm very sorry about that uh and
probably we'll we'll cut the stream
short a bit
uh due to that all right let's uh
continue pushing since we can
yeah what's happening here
and push further
okay and go all the way
is there some sneaky move he doesn't
want to take my rook
so that's fine
super fine yeah i don't want to trade
here but
i guess i guess i shouldn't yeah let's
try this
and try and sneak this in let's try and
sneak this in yeah we've sneaked it in
it's pretty cool oh
yeah we got made it we got made it
oh yeah that's the stuff and that's the
stuff
oh if you can't hear anything then
that's cool i thought it'd be
uh you know possible to hear it
oh yeah i was trying to sneak one in and
then he snuck it in
that's it's unfortunate good game
dilemma
all right who do we have uh big bazooka
big bazooka there we go we haven't
played big bazooka
oh i wasn't going for an extra pawn i
had a mating
web planned i just uh completely missed
that uh
okay what's this but it's something that
happens
when you fail to develop this bishop in
the scandinavian
uh okay so he's really playing weird
that's uh ignoring the don't bring your
queen out too early
so we'll see uh yeah let's defend it and
prepare this
just to harass the queen a little bit
more
yeah it's not not the smartest of moves
i'm just trying to get the queen to hang
out hang in there for as long as
possible
here we go more moves with the queen
try and do try to do even more uh
yeah okay let's uh let's do this
okay yeah that's that's the stuff
i think he now saw that he's low on time
and that he's
he shouldn't play so much with the queen
and he decided to just give it up
all right so that's pretty cool
and that as well all right let's push
that
okay a nice fork here i'm not saying it
isn't
let's capture this first
uh get that guy in
yeah let's let's go here go for some uh
queen
quincy reaction
yeah first oh we can just grab that yeah
i guess that's also possible
uh yeah let's uh let's do a nice mate in
one
i think a nice mate in one will do
yeah the dancing queen on the board
never never a good idea
hey uh ayush welcome man
welcome to the team yeah big big barnes
bazooka
online welcome man hey
over hero thank you for the for the for
such nice words man
really appreciate it kalireza
challenging to uh what is this
oh that's oh that's with one second
increment oh we don't play that
i will play it play this one since i
accepted but
uh we we don't play uh increment here
at least not for this stream that's a
free night
so uh thanks thanks for that
and now we have our extra second to
enjoy our free night so that's pretty
pretty awesome yeah let's just bring the
knight back and castle
oh he's really coming for us there let's
uh try and break up the center a little
bit
okay yeah we'll we can do that
we can play that as well oh a nice
in-between move
nice very nice
yeah let's get the knight in somewhere
nice to control some dark squares
yeah he has that okay we want to
sometimes play something like this and
get the queen in maybe
but also bring the rooks in wouldn't
wouldn't be a terrible idea
uh yeah now this is this is game
not uh nothing not in the way that now
it's game over but adjusting the way
that
it is playable
okay uh interesting let's bring the rook
in
and here now there are some very nasty
ideas here
being threatened
okay i guess uh maybe maybe a queen
trade wasn't
necessary there but why not
why not let's try and trap the bishop
unless he hears me yeah and i can't play
on time because it's with one second
increment so we have to be
careful here you know you have to be
careful when you're when you're up an
extra rook there's no joking around
uh i guess we take that this is defended
uh yeah let's uh let's go here go for
this guy
yeah okay that's a free one
uh let's go here and here
yeah i guess now we take we don't wanna
waste too much time here
there we go and that's mate all right
that was pretty pretty nice
yeah no no horsing around
hey man
oh i could have played f4 immediately
and win the bishop really
why why didn't i do it instead of this
how i push f4 he goes here and i don't
have g5 how could i have won the bishop
immediately
am i missing something i could be
i'm not saying i'm not
uh who do we have
um bd bd07 we haven't played bd
could be
okay i mean if you guys say the bishop
is trapped i mean i believe you it's not
like it's not like i don't believe you
guys i know you guys are
are extremely good at chess
okay so now he wants to play this and
this and we we don't want that
so let's try castle art officially here
he's super fast
so what's that we just gave up a pawn
oh no we could have captured it he he's
so fast that he tricked me
he tricked me into believing that uh
that he actually won a pawn that's
that's pretty crazy
wow okay that's cool
that's cool uh let's go for this
i guess
yeah that's interesting a triple attack
here on the f2 pawn
and also there oh and it's uh
my turn that's pretty cool
so a lot of mating ideas here uh and
uh one presents itself pretty much uh
right away so let's do this
there there could have been a faster one
i'm just solo on time i don't even
i don't even realize it he's like super
instantly playing everything
uh yeah let's uh i mean let's take take
that guy as well
what is happening here
he's avoiding my moves so so cleanly
oh one second on the clock that's crazy
oh that's uh also not uh yeah mate
missed i i know that there was a
mate missed uh somewhere in there so
here
probably uh a nicer move would be i
don't know
yeah but no this is good this is good
and now
oh yeah that's that's meeting one wow
woof
have to play play more puzzles this is
this is embarrassing yeah that's meeting
one
all right fair enough
no no there was mate in there there was
mate in there make no mistake
great white elephant mila all right mila
uh i've never tried a sub battle and i
don't know how it works
uh and what is it but yeah
if you guys are interested at some point
yeah we can we can do one
against someone at some point maybe
maybe when we grow the channel a bit
more
uh i was wondering uh i will also
include one game i enjoy very much
okay that king is in the center way too
long
uh have you guys ever played super meat
boy
or or heard of it
okay so now we're just gonna get this
bishop in this bishop in push c5
yeah so at least get make the
light square bishop come alive he's
gonna capture that no he won't
even that wow
no not super meat balls super meat boy
it's really a really a crazy game
and an enjoyable one okay not really
happening anything
nothing happening here let's give up
that night
oh not interested in the night
yeah super meat boy will do that
all right good good smothered mate there
well not really smothered but a
nightmare not a nice mate a night mate
team from one channel play against the
team from other channel
oh okay but is there like an option for
that or
is it just like imaginary maybe
like what chess.com has like an option
for that
yeah knife f5 yeah knife f5 yeah
all right uh beginner is
challenging to a three plus so all right
we played we played the winner we
haven't played winner but the winner
disappeared so
it's a gaetano
am i good at checkers no no i played
like uh maybe
one one or one two three games uh oh i
actually wanted to play b4 here this is
not what i wanted to play
no let's not trade like without
without any any point now we trade
captures captures go back
and now we have the bishop pair from
hell is fully operational now let's
let's make use of it
i like this pawn here i don't want it
here so let's
get a knight in there i don't want
his bishop to come alive as well okay
now i have to kick it back
because he's going after this square
now we go here yeah that's
that's fair
yeah the bishop is good going for this
okay so we get our rook
in and what do we have
we don't have much that's that is true
oh that's interesting
is there something here no there isn't
he wants to
he wants to get rid of our dark square
bishop so we kind of have to allow it
there's no way around it yeah
that's the problem there so we're going
after some
some critical squares here not a lot of
them
and we're gonna we're hoping to get
to make a breakthrough here either the
knight moves or we capture it or
something
bishop f4 looks weird like really weird
but maybe it's possible i don't know i
have no idea what that is so we're just
going to ignore it
uh is this good
is this good with five seconds on the
clock i think it is
what he he doesn't want to capture it
that's pretty crazy let's see if he
picks this up okay i just wanted to
check if he will spot
that uh the queen is hanging the problem
is he was trying to go here but he
couldn't and he didn't see that
the my queen was hanging so we tried a
cheapo there
it paid off it paid off but you know
uh usually usually it doesn't
yat welcome yahoo and falcon456
hey nick nick bfh welcome to the team
man
thanks for that uh thanks for the nice
cloud versus sephiroth uh
animation all right what do we have
uh anaramar uh have we played against
you
i know you just joined the channel but i
don't know if i don't can't remember if
we played
yeah today's uh today is a bullet today
to celebrate international chess day
there we go all right
so playing fast i like that
now let's go f5 to prevent him from
capturing this ever
and we're happy and get this knight in
probably all the way there
uh but maybe not just yet uh
why is he giving up a pawn here
so there was an agenda i just don't know
what what it is
okay it's fair
everything is fair unless unless it's
not
so i want to get this guy in here okay
it's pretty cool and i have no idea what
that
is uh that's a free piece i would say
unless he gives up the exchange although
he's doing better on time so
it's not really an issue okay so i see
what you're doing
let's try and do it this way
uh yeah no mate here unfortunately
so we can try we can try like this
he doesn't have a way to enter with the
rook
so we're gonna make it uh make it
interesting
with 15 seconds on the clock as
interesting as it can be
there we go okay
there we go and there we go we're not
gonna
give up that guy there we go and there
we go
and there we go he's just gonna try and
do something
to win on time but we're not gonna allow
it
okay let's take that
a nice dark square
okay he's really really trying to get in
there we go oh that was a a true flag
off
i did not expect you to be this this
quick at flagging
that that was a good flag off good game
man
all right uh so good game
anarmar that was that was very crazy
the master eight all right master eight
let's do this
and also uh in roku
all right let's see let's see what's
happening
uh we still go for the scandinavian
right we
we we always had a good game okay here
we just uh
get a very pleasant uh game with black
very happy oh i me i totally didn't see
what he played
so we're gonna have to play really fast
to
to even try and do something here yeah
he's
not allowing it which is of course fine
uh he gives up a pawn i will take it
wow uh that's uh that's when you're
playing a little bit too fast
uh also not a great idea
let's completely box this king in
and yeah i thought i had mate i i don't
so that's very sad
um let's go even further yeah let's take
a queen here
there we go
all right so making it last as long as
possible that was pretty crazy
matt welcome mat book
yeah i need to show barnes winning
sometimes
actually the game most of the games that
barnes won were not recorded at least to
my knowledge
uh only the like the really awesome ones
like where he played f6 against morphe
supras corona welcome man
uh so that that is a shame yeah
uh who do we have here who do we have
here
junior bbr
what haven't we played we played e4 but
we're gonna play it more
since everyone lives loves a good b for
action all right we're gonna
dislodge the knight uh
get some d4 action in
it's pretty pretty cool
see what happens okay that's interesting
uh let's
play interestingly we're hanging on the
verge of defeat here since this is mate
so we have to be very careful here
yeah we're gonna castle here take
try and take advantage of this night
looking weird
uh yeah that's good we're gonna open up
this attack although we've sacrificed we
don't
we're not trying to win more material uh
so that's not not what's happening here
do we capture here and then pick up the
bishop i guess we do but no this is with
check oh now we've blundered it
completely
we have one now he has this oh he just
uh we lost everything
this is no longer playable unfortunately
but we will still try and win on time
somehow yeah let's
keep this alive try and force f5
in yeah f5 would be good if he goes for
it he doesn't
let's try this
okay
not interested not interested
yeah he can just give up anything for
anything and he's still better okay now
now he messed up he's still better but
uh
he's still better but whoa
but i can maybe maybe force a win here
check go here go here
there we go a nice check for the for the
flagging victory
oh wait a second it's not the mailman
all right that was a that was a very
nice flag off
uh and the welcome
all right so uh we'll be streaming for
11 more minutes
and that's it uh for the for the morning
stream
we i have some videos planned for for
later on and then maybe maybe a nice
evening stream as well at
fully you know celebrate international
chess day
yeah meadow snacks arrived that is true
uh architect oh architect also alicia
supporter
so let's enjoy a good game so we're
continuing with e4
he's going for some sort of a modern
approach which is cool
that's a free pawn he doesn't want it
it's very interesting
now let's go c4 i guess i can go
kingside castle although
it's not much fun okay that's really
going for it
really going going for it hard uh let's
go rook
here and at some point push f4 probably
yeah that's good that's a that's a good
good good decision good decision making
right there
yeah let's go back
all right that's uh his bishops are
doing very good work
although i could have captured it
actually i i think that's exactly what
i'm gonna do
uh let's get this guy away from there
let's do this and what is being
threatened now
not much my bishops are are good okay
he's threatening to pick up the rook
which makes me a little bit sad now i
gave up a bishop he doesn't want it
so it's pretty crazy yeah crazy stuff
happening here let's just bring those
bishops
back uh force force a queen trade here
yeah he wants to deliver some sort of a
sneaky mate but we're not
we're not buying it yeah he wants to go
here some sort of a check
uh yeah i kind of have to capture it
and now we now we're dead here
really yeah we're dead here
are we dead here yeah we are
yeah we're dead here we there's no
escaping oh man
was there an escape this actually worked
wow that's cool
that's really awesome yeah maybe there
was an escape
like check check okay but after this
point i don't know
is there stopping queen h4
yeah those bishops were really a tomb
rather than anything else
yeah no there's no is there one bishop h
yeah bishop h2 still queen h4 you don't
you don't gain anything from it
queen a8 followed by queen c8 oh queen
a8
check followed by queen c8 there we go
yeah
yeah queen eight followed by quincy h
that's the stuff i knew there was some
sort of a sneaky maneuver yeah
so check king something or this then
quincy check and just queen back yeah
that's the stuff the the op
chat uh knows knows uh
knows the stuff uh but the great game
uh architect very much enjoyed that
queen maneuver
volley
are you still lose after e6 oh did we
did we not see that coming okay then
there there was maybe more to analyze to
this game than we
originally thought all right so let's
exploit something here
something something uh we're gonna go
h6 go all the way leela style all the
way
so that's a good attack on their c5
probably happening at some point
uh let's force him to trade
yeah we want to force him to trade so we
can go f4
yeah and he wants to go c5 of course
that's uh that is how you do it but this
is now a free
a free win yeah nothing much happening
there
an absolute free win so uh i guess we
can even
push this even give up that guy
can we no how do you blunder like that
that's insane i mean
i think we still win here but uh
but we have to be a little bit more
careful
and yeah he's much better on time yeah
okay we do capture this now and this is
now
this is no game i believe because check
and
picks that up and that's good that's
what's that's what's good here
yeah we pick that up uh we go back
and now we have that yeah okay that was
pretty good
this uh luck that we we
caught when we figured out that knight
d5 was winning
yeah in 10 ish minutes that's that's
putting it well
joseph portal and per nile skipper
welcome guys and geofricks
welcome geofricts uh all right that's
why we're playing bullet today to accept
as many challenges as possible
uh pepega all right pepega welcome to
pega
you just arrived and you know
i clicked it okay again with the
sicilian let's go b4
uh all right d5 happening
actually queen f6 wins here for black
but no one ever finds that so
but no i i should have gone d6 first wow
i i i'm telling you what wins for black
and then i miss what wins for white
ha it's pretty crazy
but it's fine uh
oh there's some message deleting here
what's happening in the chat
whoa what's happening when i'm not
looking
hey hello everyone
if you got yeah we'll see if we maybe we
can throw in some more
some more bullet games later on okay so
we're gonna capture this definitely go
for d6 this is
this is defended let's capture that he
has some nice discoveries probably but
he doesn't he doesn't use them
wisely so yeah
let's try this although he can just do
pretty much anything this yeah
although he he will allow me to uh
to do to to not do it so let's
try and keep our seep on at least okay
now
now it's very interesting
uh okay i'm i'm lost here
i'm lost here but he's doing very well
on time so let's try
and get him to capture with the knight
so we can get some pieces in there
uh which is fine okay he does go for the
night
uh which is kind of cool since i now
have this
uh yeah we pick up that that's that's
not an issue
not in the least uh yeah let's uh do
anything
really just anything we'll will do
nicely here
so the knight has no squares since we've
covered all the squares okay pepeka that
was that was a good game
do i think in english or in my native
language uh sometimes in english
sometimes uh
depends if i'm talking to myself then in
english if i'm just you know thinking
then probably creation
that sounds much weirder than i meant it
to sound actually
sanchez sama welcome man welcome to the
team
and also welcome ali
uh don't ban me please
knock don't ban me please no okay
checkmate sucks yeah it does suck to be
checkmated
uh all right so we're we i think we have
time for two more games
and that's it for this stream so let's
make it another scandinavian
a nicely played one hopefully
let's castle and we will always play h
here
until someone actually accepts it
uh okay now maybe not since now we're
gonna capture this to see if he can
punish me for my insolence
uh now we're gonna develop the bishop
yeah it's time to develop the bishop
if we don't develop the bishop then bad
things start happening
yeah uh what what is this
it's something something
yeah let's not blunder our queen like
right away so
that's a free pawn try really wasting
too much time here
uh do we have like uh in-betweener here
yeah we kind of do but not a good one
is that knight doing anything at all not
really
yeah not really okay
so we just go back no we don't yeah
that's that was pretty bad of me
that was pretty bad yeah he just grabs
the pawn and he says ha ha
he can just laugh in my face okay that's
oh wow
good job man that is good that is that
is very clean
very clean
very clean
okay play rogue you want please oh damn
it
now he has this check come on
wow with this
check he is invincible
there we go
okay now we try and flag him although it
will not be easy
oh good game man that was a good game
i did not expect that uh queen sacrifice
that was beautiful
that was beautiful let's see that one
more time in slow motion
see how he tricked me i thought yes
rookie 8 and he just
laughs in my face with this bishop move
oh yeah now if captures then this is
mate
that was that was beautiful don't ban me
please okay
oh that was you okay if that was you
then congratulations
uh i have to turn on uh analysis board
to do a slow motion replay
uh yeah so now we can do it like let's
see that
rook captures queen and the rook
cap rook delivers mate there we go
beautiful stuff
all right so time for one more uh who we
haven't played
uh i'm actually that's a one plus one
omer oh yeah we haven't played omar we
haven't played put on
uh alright so sup
sub4 there we go
but we're gonna play we're gonna play
more if you guys enjoy like these short
bullet challenges uh i mean we can
always play uh
but we have to avenge the scandinavian
for the previous game
so we have to play it again he in fact
did punish us for our insolence trying
that we removed
yeah we're still gonna play this
until someone accepts no nothing okay
so this is a move definitely my king is
on a dark
on a light square so he doesn't have any
checks to win my queen
uh although that can change like any any
day
all right threatening some ideas here
uh yeah okay i mean if
it's uh if it's allowed we can do that
um let's go here i don't really gain
anything by this by giving this
check so we're not even gonna do it uh
yeah what to do that's that's the better
question like something like this
give up a pawn or two
now we go g5 oh that's nice
it's actually very nice
it seems we we will not be avenging the
scandinavian
any anytime soon
ah let's do this yeah not not the
greatest
yeah let's let's go back he's
threatening our rook so that's not fun
huh oh wow
oh wow actually that was that was pretty
crazy
oh wow oh
we we had a good run for these uh past
few games but
then these last two scandinavian games
are just terrible
alright so let's try and pick something
up at least
uh yeah let's not do that hope he
blunders the queen
yes he blunders the queen now now it's
fair game
now it's fair game but he didn't just
blunder it i was hoping he blunders it
okay so now we have to do something and
there's not much to do
there we go we can we can run away it's
it's that easy
and we win by flagging that's the stuff
all right so he was extremely fast there
but
we were we were able to do it yeah
that was that was good all right so uh
thank you all for joining in to this
very early uh stream on the
international chess day
uh make sure to tune in later on youtube
to check out some morphe versus barnes
action and we'll see maybe
maybe something uh something you know we
can also
make something like this uh in the
evening we'll see how it goes
welcome man yeah thanks everyone for
joining in and
until next time guys
there we go
barnes op barnes op there we go
later guys